[Musique]
cette photo sortie dans la presse a
rendu fou les internautes on y voit
Léonardo Dicaprio côté d'Eden polany une
jeune mannequin de 19 ans avec qui il
serait en couple fréquenté des femmes
plus jeunes que lui une habitude pour
l'acteur de 48 ans qui enchaîne les
conquêtes comme la teste ce graphique
presque toutes ces dernières petites
amies avaient moins de 25 ans comme
Camilla Moron 22 ans
et aujourd'hui l'importante différence
d'âge avec sa nouvelle copine de 19 ans
choc de nombreuses personnes alors
comprenez vous l'acharnement contre
DiCaprio
c'est exactement la même différence
d'âge qu'avec mon voilà mon premier
amoureux mystérieux c'était exactement
la même différence et je trouve ça
génial
quand tu avais 19 ans il avait 18 ans il
avait 5 ans donc c'est quasiment pareil
donc et je trouve ça génial il est là il
aime des choses en fait
[Rires]
tu nous regardes de là-haut Gaston
on t'embrasse c'était parti avec tous
tes secrets
comment on n'a pas avoir le prénom
c'est plus près de Gaston
non non non non non non non non
[Applaudissements]
elle nous a dit qu'il était excusé
sur Léonardo Dicaprio quoi vous vous
êtes choqué vous
je suis pas contre non je suis pas
contre la différence d'âge mais à partir
d'un certain âge je suis désolé voilà à
partir de 25 ans on peut aller avec
quelqu'un de 25 ans plus c'est pas le
problème c'est à 25 ans
à 19 ans en dessous de 20 ans non je
suis désolé
lui avant lui elle avait quelqu'un qui
était également âgé
donc elle aime les hommes plutôt mûrs
mais toi sur le dossier
j'adore Léonardo Dicaprio que j'ai déjà
rencontré ah oui oui deux fois deux fois
on s'est croisé dans un
aéroporté en fait on était on s'est
croisé
non parce que les gens nous ont présenté
un aéroport normal ou un aéroport mais
dans quelle ville ça peut te [__]
Sarreguemines on ne dites
thank you
aussi il m'a fait venir un jour à sa
table
et puis j'avais une table parce que
j'avais souvent c'était il y a cinq six
ans et j'avais une table réservée par le
patron qui était un pote au grand jambe
et du coup un jour il vient me voir il
me dit Jean-Michel je suis obligé de te
décaler tu rigoles pourquoi il me dit il
y a une star qui arrive une star plus
important que moi un peu 20 minutes plus
tard je vois 3 black qui arrive des
garde du corps comme ça qui investissent
les lieux etc et Caprio qu'avec une
casquette une lettre de soleil etc et
personne ne pouvait l'approcher vous en
foutez de ce que je raconte ou pas
et du coup mais moi j'étais atteignable
donc tout le monde venait me faire des
photos avec moi pour me demander Siri et
comment dans la vie etc les photos comme
ça au bout d'un moment il était à trier
que tout le monde vient de me voir faire
des photos et du coup il a demandé à la
garde du corps de venir me chercher en
même temps Wario ça je lui ai dit just
Jona et French journaliste des litiges
etc et comme ça il m'a regardé et puis
il m'a fait genre enfin j'ai Go je suis
resté une minute planté devant lui puis
au non j'ai compris il fallait que je
peux venir
du grand écran 7e
il me dégoûte ce mec là chez lui cet
après-midi au téléphone il dit que pas
du tout je suis votre coach de vie non
non mais je te jure alors bah tes
conseils tu peux te fous je pense en
fait plus vieillit plus l'âge de ses
conquêtes 10 minutes donc au début
c'était 25 24 23 lundi
la question qu'il faut se poser pardon
mais est-ce qu'elle serait allé avec lui
si c'était pas Léonardo Dicaprio mais
est-ce que ta meuf elle sera avec toi
c'était pas gagné
mais arrête de dire des conneries tu
t'es vu ta meuf c'est un avion tu crois
qu'elle sera avec toi
j'ai un peu tu me dis avec ma première
femme j'avais 10 ans d'écart avec ma
deuxième femme 20 et puis maintenant ma
troisième femme 30 ah voilà voilà ça se
termina l'histoire
ça fait quoi ça fait deux gars comme ça
je vous présenterai pas ma femme elle a
l'air dégourdi
ça choque là oh ça me choque bah il fait
ce qu'il veut s'il veut pécho des meufs
qui le fassent écoute
ouais moi je m'en fous moi chacun fait
ce qu'il veut c'est ça
moi je suis un mec cool ouais tu juge
pas toi oh non non moi je m'en fous
chacun fait ce qu'il veut
ah summer je pensais que tu parlais de
l'été
[Rires]
les violences conjugales là ils sont
tous les deux consentants ils sont
majeurs
communs voilà ils sortent ensemble très
bien et les messieurs qui gueule c'est
les mêmes qui quand ils divorce sortent
avec après une meuf de 20 ans de moins
avant je me demande si c'était l'inverse
si ce serait plus choquant ou moins
choquant par exemple une comédienne très
connue très riche
de 19 ans
ça passerait pareil
vous êtes à l'ancienne les gars je suis
pas d'accord ça passe
Clément
Daniel non mais j'ai essayé d'imaginer
c'est comme si toi tu sortais avec
Daniel
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pas du tout mais moi je trouve même que
cette coupe idéale et puis excuse-moi
Guillaume le
marché je te donne ma jeunesse si tu me
donnes ta célébrité c'est Jean-Jacques
de 50 ans il était chez évidemment
correct de dire parce que les gens vont
dire oui chacun a droit de faire ce
qu'il veut on a le droit de dire qu'on
est choqué aussi c'est une fille à peine
majeur
moi je suis désolé ça me choque de voir
son âge
[Applaudissements]
attention
de l'homme et pas de la femme comme si
elle elle est mannequin elle travaille
elle voyage dans le monde entier mais
c'est pas la femme qui me choque c'est
l'homme mais pourquoi pas moi j'ai 31
ans
d'être michto elle a tous les draps plus
ou moins de droits que l'homme et nous
on a le droit d'être choqué mal à l'aise
moi ça m'est malaise de voir ça c'est
tout voilà après vous pensez ce que vous
voulez je suis d'accord parce que entre
19 ans et 25 ans psychologique
il y a un ascendant psychologique et un
ascendant financier c'est un mec qui est
blindé c'est quoi ta moto
elle est vraiment vraiment
je juge pas
ils sont majeurs elle est majeures il
est majeure sans problème mais elle est
quand même né en 2004 moi ça me paraît
bizarre il parle de quoi il arrive
bientôt 50 ans elle en a même pas 20 ans
on peut voir la meuf s'il vous plaît
alors
vraiment et ben l'amour n'a pas d'âge
[Applaudissements]
non mais les deux je les connais mais
tout le monde dit non les deux qui
disent oui c'est les deux pires non mais
sans déconner
c'est horrible mais ça me dégoûte je les
connais mais les mecs mais je veux pas
que je les connais par cœur je les ai
écrit
dis-moi l'autre Baba tu crois qu'il
disait la même chose quand il prenait
des balles de cul dans le dans le cul
c'est bon arrête un peu arrête un peu
chanson 47 2004
ans 25 ans à partir 25 ans ça va alors
24 ans et 11 mois non là ça passe pas
comme les deux 86 tu connais ta meuf ou
euh 25 ans d'écart
franchement quand je vous vois tous les
deux ça ça choque
pour mature et ensemble surtout quoi je
crois que c'est cohérent mais on s'aime
surtout c'est cohérent
j'aurais choisi tout de suite mais on
sait arrête non je trouve ça hyper bien
ensemble je te le dis bien sûr